Here's how I found the answers.
To evaluate A at these
fourth roots of unity,
I first evaluated this polynomial
Ae at the second roots of unity.
Note that Ae here is 1 plus x.
Thus Aee, the even of those terms,
is just 1.
And Aoe is the odd of those terms,
the coefficient here is 1 as well.
So I can just write 1 and
1 in those slots.
Applying these formulas then
tells me that Ae of 1 is 2 and
Ae of negative 1 is 0.
With this done, now I'm ready to find
the values of Ao at its roots of unity.
Ao consists of the odd coefficients
here, so it's 0 minus x,
and the even of these is the 0 and
the odd of those is negative 1.
So I go ahead and
write those in those slots.
Applying these formulas then tells
me that Ao of one is negative 1 and
Ao of negative 1 is 1.
With all these values computed
we can now apply the rules for
our final layer to obtain the answer
which I calculated to be this.